signori signor signor ami amici tutti
tutti parenti cani che abbiamo scritto
la storia di youtube
giusto per non ti lasciano il tub italia
ovviamente nel 2001 2013 questo fu uno
degli horror più belli che io giocai e
sono qua riproporlo perché comunque non
mi ricordo una setta tra john krystal
vantaggi può essere non esistono salva
taci taci tu a allora non mi ricordo
niente ma proprio niente se non che il
cattivo del gioco è un manichino che ti
segue e quando non lo guardi ti tocchi
taccia il cancello meritano gli orange
in the use of two challenger king bio e
beck qui a mettermi porta l'ingresso
gioca a scacchi riscatti dei maghi qua
per te amico niente intanto nei comandi
però buongiorno prendo lancio faccio
perfetto mi ricordo ragazzi che ai tempi
tutti i giochi prendevano tutti un po
ispirazione da d'amnesia una roba del
genere perché amnesia era proprio
diventato un bel gioco number one della
storia quindi tenore fighissimo
questo è lo zio lo zio come ecco questo
ha terrorizzato youtube italia 2013 per
me compreso non mi ricordo niente se non
che c'è un modo per insomma gestirsi
tutto questo auguri però non mi ricordo
bisogna andare effettivamente devi stare
fermo se io vado di là tu stai non è che
stai ti muovi si erge una statua di
bronzo sia una statua di stronza di
bronzo sovrappiù lista pro comunque
allora fate fate cast mettiamo subito le
cose in chiaro perché sono qua non ci
capisce una porta aperta al meno male
perché effettivamente
le altre sono tutte chiuse comunque
allegro meno male creava in meno vuol
dire la antologia parziale di henry
cornelis agrippa sbaglio agri però
neanche gli amnesia c'è tra l'altro
c'entra niente col tasto racing sul
vostro primo anno lascia manipolare
manipolare determinati oggetti con la
formalità ma ci sono state calmi perché
qua nessuno mi ha preparato a terremoti
o cose e ti fa vedere dove dove dove
puoi andare là per j
ho trovato un modellino di scali una
cantina dei vini si incastra
perfettamente con quello che ho visto in
grande
lo devo andare a ficcare dentro proprio
bilancio aveva aperto sono venuto un po
di vento nel chupete cadeau per terra
pensate ben active gola fa miracoli
ecco infatti non c'è più lo zio lo zio
so che questa è casa tua ma non fare
cioè insomma vino si facciano tutto
quanto è perché megan non è che dobbiamo
essere scortesi solo perché sei un
manichino di bronzo che devo fare
porta gli altri modelli nelle stanze
fino al tavolo per esplorare
ulteriormente la villa e cioè io l'ho
fico al contrario in modo tale che poi
posso entrare dall'altra entrata perché
adesso io sposto le stanze fighissimo
milano ma ricordo per niente salina mica
bellissimo quindi adesso è chiuso però
qua non dovrebbe essere aperto perfetto
e c'è il contrario perché l'ho messa al
contrario è un annuncio a tutti gli
impiegati della carecre del mezzo awards
l'altra i fannulloni è il fannulloni non
mi hanno fatto figli leggerlo e quindi
sono un fannullone 4 strappato qualcosa
ha fatto a pezzi in questo quadro per un
mezzo di indagine i sottili graffi
allora lovino o vino orso demonio che è
successo
ho visto che c'era qualcuno mi sbaglio
mi scusi casa sua questa che io non ho
ancora non capì crede il meno vuol dire
la magione di crecc raven ma meno vuol
dire ma perché kasami caso è la vuoi un
po di vino frase si prospettava saladino
sostegno come i come me ed autorevole
volentieri ma immagino sia chiusa la
porta
avrei fatto motion www io uscirei ma
laporta sta chiusa e non è che posso
premier e l'ex chief ventesimo vinto per
scattare lungo corridoio elezioni
sa che cazzo di niente
la leva dove sei
se n'è andato sarà ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta le slot gara out volentieri zio un
certo modellino camera da letto
comunque se volete possiamo anche
finirla molto impatti con un bicchiere
di brandy tutto sul re tutto sul bene
suo gioco savini tutto che non me ne
frega un cazzo di vino non bevo solo
acqua minerale e ogni tanto alta la
pesca ai partner che sempre quindi
facciamo i seri questo lo piccolo e
voglio anche intercooler come le slot
dove come si gira ok metto come topolino
ma chi se ne frega della della come
metti le stanze certo punto ovviamente
anche a casa
bello show telefono iphone 13
mi sembra strano che effettivamente sta
a casa ci sia tra i rotto le palle
fattelo dire frate ovi offre un
bicchiere d estate o non me ne vado
testa di culo dove come fatto uscire
allora c'è un solo un punto dopo essere
andato no no cazzo se la porta come
aiuto
non me l'aspettavo mai non promette bene
però spacchettamento trovo un calciatore
totti ci prendiamo una vecchia asse di
legno ricoperta di sangue addirittura ai
sangue web savino 4 tomino non c'e
nessuno gli ha proseguito un mucchio di
fotografia pure esco card e ri 36 uomini
e donne nudi decorati con schizzi di
vernice rossa danzano attorno un globo
di vetro non me ne frega niente andiamo
avanti
mi fa piacere ritaglio di giornale era
una magari era una statuina stupida va
bene c'è tutta una storia dietro
comunque che non ho voglia di leggere
che sono pigro e quindi non lo farò
però almeno ben leggono almeno almeno
imposte al sono allegri ragazzi
ragazzi questa di pigna ma [ __ ]
brutto bronzo pronto di bronzo e femmine
apro la porta sei fermo è chiusa padre
la tua casa tua testa rimini dove vado
io qua esco cosa no no no stai salve si
sveglia e si spegne la torcia che lo fa
da prendere di librino sono molto forti
mai toccare un libro per favore no
ragazzi orribile ci aiuta
c'è un quadro che ha peso che si stacca
si stacca il quadro non lo farete lo fai
quel che faccio che faccio ad ordinare
il cosolini cosa che non riesco a fare
sintesi cosa si muova che fastidio
no ragazzi giorni di milano gioco
orribile vi prego fatemi finire questa
purga vecchio diario non me ne faccio
niente tirare ma a è sparito tra l'altro
suo ca dove andate
tira tira su 4 giu il quadro porco del
demonio catena due ore per la porta nice
chiudila almeno a william craven
effettivo e credo che ci sia tutta una
questione di questo qua faceva
esperimenti e ha creato manichini che si
muovono pagina stampa non lo so poi
ragazzi non ho idea modello della
soffitta ok la soffitta mi interessa
perché gli altri erano poco allegri sono
convinto che la soffitta sarà una botta
di vita questo gioco
ok ok questa porta a sinistra destra
questo almeno dal quadro del lupo che
sia molto più allegro suo posto che
tutto il resto ma veramente fa vice sta
rifacendo sto gioco questa espressione
io ho spiegato il perché a quella faccia
non mi fanno incazzare già sapete questo
per di no no
[Musica]
6 perché penso che non solo studiato io
aiuto che succedano nicchia pensavo di
non so perché nella mia testa pensavo
attiva se qualcosa tipo un quadro invece
non era una soffitta giustamente
sappiamo il modo di della soffitta però
la soffitta non promette bene anche
perché sento rumori di gente che strisce
quindi no no no no no no no no
che cacchio fai sta dietro il vetro lo
zio ti 6 dimenticato c è una botte nella
botte piccola c'è il vino bona che però
rimane piccola prodotto lancio non si
possono lanciare de rossi per lanciarsi
prevista studenteschi tour dai madonna
può essere più tipici e centra un buco
storia della mia vita salvata ginko
comunque ragazzi non ho ancora capito
bene la storia a distanza di otto anni
il suo gioco come la dovrà spiegare nei
commenti ingranaggio questo lo devo
prendere perché mi serve per il pannello
di fuori che però se crolla tutto salve
a tanto si è aperta strada fantastico
eccolo modello della libreria ci sarà un
modo per prendere l'ingranaggio ma non è
questo il momento
sei un po stronzo per ora devi stare
fermo per cortesia santo di dio frate no
toretto visto però adesso e non vale
cioè solo quando ti guardo 16 usein bolt
devo passare lo stesso arrivederci bene
niente mettiamo la libreria che ha due
entrate tra l'altro ok
dov'è che devo andare in fondo in fondo
a sinistra va bene non ha le tasche non
ha le mani perché vi cadono le cose e
soprattutto nella resistenza
sembro io sto personaggio sembro io
realistico a devo ficcare proprio la tua
bella ed emette i ragazzi di maniglia
funzionante invece fa ste cagate qua
era un preludio al test a ragazzo era un
preludio al cosa devo fare
effettivamente io ti schiaccio no non mi
toccare il cervello che no è sbagliato
io devo trovare la giusta combination
bene madonna lo sento che si muove non
capisco come va bene va bene va bene
allora salve e molto sexy quando si
ammassa così però non sono no no no no
sulle terre che mancano sonora forma di
no e faccio tutto fasullo
tutto ok dov'è a questo andato ferma
tifo immobile come cibo
vediamo se riesco a tirano le canon ho
capito dovevo andare effettivamente sono
altri vi fasulli questo non è perché lo
schiaccia il primo proprio lì devo
andare testa di culo thyssen e hanno
scherzato tra l'altro dove l'ho perso e
questo soprattutto gioca questo avevamo
fatto nel 2013 quindi era per la gloria
good old times un pesante ornamento di
bronzo a sì perché non schiacciato e mi
ha cacciata del pezzo di questo è il suo
intestino e rapallo ragazzi sento
sospiri nell'anima santo iddio che se
devi scoreggia magico fallo dall'altra
parte per favore perché già un casino
questo in campo di bronzo sembra che
prevedeva ben svegli ragazzino gruppi il
primo episodio di credem e non ce ne
saranno due ma spero che vi piacciono
tantissimo perché questa era la prima
serie nell'area se è uno dei primi
giochi che ho portato su youtube breve
vuol dire tanto riportarlo quindi se vi
sia piaciuto iscritti al canale fatemi
sapere se avete continuo ma lo farò lo
stesso perché troppo bello e noi ci
vediamo come sempre al prezzo vedo nei
ragazzi
[Musica]